the group was hit by a driver in a box
truck who prosecutors say had
meth in his system reporter kate houston
joins us live at the new memorial
which has been temporarily placed near
charleston and the 2 15.
kate good evening yes this ghost bike
memorial is placed at a busy
intersection and
bike path in the hopes that it will
bring awareness to both drivers
and cyclists now this memorial here is a
white
tandem bike with the first letter of
each of the cyclists names
now spelling out team g hundreds of
family
friends and cyclists showed up to the
memorial this morning
it was extremely emotional with loved
ones taking some time to speak to the
crowd
many shedding tears as they remembered
the lives of those who were lost
everyone had an opportunity to then sign
the ghost bike
and place bright flowers around the
handlebars and wheels
at one point every cyclist raised their
bike in the air
chanting no more ghost bikes i spoke to
david murray
who lost his youngest brother michael in
the crash he says his brother will now
be able to ride
forever they're now above
looking down on us they're a team again
and they can ride without any
restrictions or any problems
and i just that was his dream that was
his goal that was his life
and i just wanted to go on to go on
forever
right now the las vegas cyclist memorial
is collecting donations for the families
of the victims
as well as the survivors they've raised
nearly 300
thousand dollars of their one million
dollar goal the group is also launching
a public awareness campaign
to educate the community about nevada's
three feet or move over passing law
designed to keep cyclists safe on the
road now back out here live this
memorial will stay here for a few months
it will then be moved to a location on
the east side before finding a permanent
resting spot
the group also plans to place five bikes
at the crash site
near searchlight reporting live tonight
from charleston in 215 kate houston 8
news now